uh hello i'm harry uh the writer and
director of supernova and i'm here with
colin firth and stanley tucci to talk
about
a specific scene uh within the film
um so the scene we've chosen to discuss
uh
is a is a crucial one in the film um for
lots of reasons
it's a scene on which the the plot
itself pivots
and in which the characters um are
forced to openly confront the truth
of their situation for for really the
foot the first time
certainly the first time in the film um
the narrative
like revelation at the heart of this
scene is one that
ushers in a new chapter in their
relationship
and also kind of announces a new act in
the film
and it's also a scene i think that
brings together many of the
narrative and cinematic elements that
precede it
in the film um up until this point the
film's been scrutinizing this
relationship
and each character's individual place uh
in it in a very delicate and restrained
way
um and there's always been a sense i
think
that up until this point we're
witnessing
the calm before the storm that there's a
showdown on its way whatever that's
going to be
so for all of these reasons it seemed
appropriate to me as a filmmaker to
try and change the visual language of
this scene
in the film uh to shift the kind of
grammar of the movie i guess uh within
the context of the the style of
filmmaking
that we're inhabiting in supernova um so
the choice to shoot this scene
in the way we did in one take always
seemed
uh to me like the most cinematically
eloquent
and dramatically pregnant choice if if
we got it right
and i felt like that from quite early on
from from almost you know script stage
actually
so the idea really is that the mechanics
of the the movie itself
for the first time are dictating the
action and the film is kind of imposing
itself
uh on the characters for the for the
first time
in the film it's literally kind of
bearing down on sam and tusca
like inexorably um which i think is um
which gives us a real sense of dramatic
inevitability
i wonder uh curious to know colin and
stanley how you guys felt
um in terms of performance because it
was always going to be quite a tough
scene to perform however we shot it i
guess
and we've been building towards it um
you know for some weeks so um
how is it for you well
for me
i don't care what colin says really i i
for no for me i think i think we were
both excited
about the way you were going to shoot it
i know i particularly love
uh single takes long single takes
i use them in as a director whenever i
can whenever it's
appropriate and as an actor i really
love them because
one it's it's sort of
like doing a little play um
and um
you you you can sustain your energy
and intention and
um and it doesn't get interrupted it
doesn't get fractured
um and usually when you're
you know you've rehearsed it quite a bit
like we did
um and i think that that
what i what i love about that is then
you know you start shooting and then you
just
you just keep you just keep going as i
said there's no there's no fracturing
of the of the process it's quite it's
quite
it can be sometimes daunting it can be
but
it's it's always challenging but but
it's also
incredibly satisfying i feel
very satisfied at the end of a day like
that
um there's a freedom i think
it forces actors to really really have
to listen to each other
and make and because if one little thing
goes off
the whole thing you gotta throw the
whole thing out the window
i love that i like that sort of
dangerous
sort of acting precipice that you're
that you're on
i love it i loved it loved it yeah
i mean i generally don't care what
stanley says either but he
i i i just happen to agree with all of
that
um yeah i for all those reasons
the the fact that it's it's your domain
um
i think you know the film versus theater
thing in terms of what advantages you
have
as an actor um i think
the you know there is a feeling
sometimes when you're filming even
though the
stakes can be very high the cameras
close in you can't lie to the lens
but there's this sense even in a
under constraint and a low budget film
and you know there aren't going to be
very many takes and there aren't going
to be very many setups
i think one can there's sometimes a
sense of security which takes the energy
away
um you know i'm going to get another
crack at this
uh the editor's gonna do something with
it
um you know that somehow it's not just
all on you and what you do in that
moment in front of the camera
maybe this isn't gonna be in the movie i
think this is often a thing in the back
of your mind when you're doing a take
that
yeah there's every chance this isn't the
movie
this moment it's it'll be take three or
something
um and i know we i don't know how many
takes we did i don't think it was more
than
three was it i think it was i think it
was three or three or
possibly four but yeah it wasn't more
than that definitely
taking that away the fact what stanley
said
you're wrong you know you're not
this has to work um it spring-loads
everything
um so that uh you know
any tiny thing that happens along the
way
uh is is going to be a part of
the final result um
and in that
in that respect you the stakes are up
there a little bit
as if you're doing a play um you know
curtains gone up
um the performance is is is the
performance this is
this is your moment
and it gives you such a a sense of the
rhythm and the time
the timing of what you're doing you know
because it's not just the idea that you
might do an overtake but also
the whole fact of the editor being
involved later
means that the rhythm of the scene is
going to be largely determined by
someone other than you
that's not the case here particularly in
in
noticeable i think in in a scene like
this because
i go off stage for quite a long time
and stanley has to hold the movie
together
um and so you and with no words
um he's you're watching waiting
[Music]
it's quite unusual to to see that and
what strikes me you know refreshing
myself watching it earlier
um was that it had this been in the
theater
i would have had to just go off stage
and count to 20
you know pick up a tape recorder from
the props thing and then come back in or
even if we'd been filming in a studio
that would probably be the case but
because the geography we had was real
i actually went to the van and got the
tape um
i don't know if you actually see me do
that do you outside the window
no no you don't you don't see a thing no
no i'm not sure why i'm
bothered
the funny thing is i think what
everything felt so real that it didn't
occur to me or anybody else
to cheat you know this is what we're
doing i actually went out the door
the van was parked where you it really
was parked when you see it in the movie
and that's where i went and
in fact when i watched it i thought gosh
that was quick i didn't i thought it
would have taken longer but i really
went there opened the door to the van
and got the tape recorded came back in
it it felt like i think for i think
certainly for me and i guess for you
guys too it felt like we were really
committing
to the honesty and the truth of of that
situation
in a different way in that in that scene
and i guess that that kind of is what
you mean as well i mean
literally going out and it taking as
long as it would literally have taken
you to do it
i think it adds a real kind of um
a real magic to that to that scene
because i think you've got
you've got like you say it's quite
strange and
uh you know unique maybe a little bit in
a film
to have a character exit stage right or
whatever and leave
another character just there for a long
time and i think that
the way that highlights the isolation
for both of you but specifically i think
for for stan um i think is really
interesting
and i wonder yeah how that felt in terms
of
you know performance standards or being
i love that i love
i love that bit i love when people walk
out of frame
you stay with one person maybe there's
dialogue
you know you never cut to the person
who's off camera then that person and
reenters they may even enter from
another place
it's so much more interesting it's so
much more cinematic than just
the positive space of i'm filming you
talking i'm filming you talking i'm
filming you talking about that
what what this does is it really makes
use of the medium
in a much more in a much more
interesting way it's all that negative
all that negative space
when he first of all between us second
of all
when he walks away that negative space
becomes
incredibly profound and is filled with
trepidation fear the audience
knows what's happening i don't know
what's happening
and it just gets filled up and it's
beautiful the shots
the shot is gorgeous um
yeah and that's that's why
because for the most part if you're
doing something in one take an extended
shot you're going to be using the space
much more than you would if you if you
were chopping it up it's just
it's it's almost inevitable unless
you're
super tight and going from face to face
and you're just you know
following somebody like that but for the
most part you're really going to use the
negative
you're really going to use the space
you're going to make use of the negative
space much more than if you're just
chopping it
up and i love that i love that that
aspect of it and for this reason
you know when i look at the the movie
and i've always i said this to a lot of
people who are zoning that you you know
you created this sort of bergmonesque
feeling
in the film this is incredibly hard to
achieve
and but and this just takes it to to
that to the next
level yeah i think um
yeah no thank you thanks yeah i think i
think it's um
i mean i don't like the film yeah yeah
you did it
me neither but um here we are um
the i think the i guess what we did do
throughout the film especially in this
scene is really like i said kind of
really commit
to the honesty and the truth of the
situation
like we didn't when we were shooting in
the van we didn't tear the van apart and
put it back together again
like that and same in same when we're in
this cottage you know those spaces
are just as they are you know and i
think that's um
that's that's a really useful uh way of
working sometimes i certainly feel that
um and this scene to me is is a
definitely a watershed moment
narratively
in the film and it felt like it needed
to be uh
you know a watershed moment
cinematically too
in in the context of the film because i
think what it does
is well it naturally it sets up what's
to come
and you know what we have after this is
some really meaty and emotionally
intense
material and i wonder whether
you guys felt that this scene kind of
unlocked that
for you guys i wonder if it sort of
became a kind of
launch pad for what we were then about
to do in the cottage because we
i suppose we did also shot pretty much
chronologically so
this happened before the day before the
next
you know the next scene around the
dinner table so i wonder if it like
worked as a launch pad in any way
well what's interesting to me uh about
how you've structured it
[Music]
and i i really noticed this going
forward but i perhaps more than i did
when we were
doing it um the way you play with
different levels
of um
truthfulness with oneself you know these
characters what what they're prepared to
acknowledge what they're prepared to
face
um how they manage things through
secrecy through uh
um
[Music]
and so much of that takes place just in
the scene
um you know these two people who are
together alone um
managing it they're in a very different
place in that process
you've got tasca who knows what he has
in mind
and knows what his deal is um
but sam who now knows but
tusker doesn't know that sam knows um
and he's that's what it's about that's
what's about to happen and he's about to
bring that together and that's the
watershed you're talking about but it's
not the watershed
it's it's one in a series of watersheds
that don't have to happen and
and and levels of of honesty and
confrontation
and what's interesting to me is you've
got um tusca
tinkling on the piano um
trying to keep the kind of daily banter
going
um sam who's now completely
spring-loaded
to make it to have this confrontation
tusker can clearly
feel that something's up and about to
happen and he's pushing something
forward
and then and it's in a way it's the
second time in the film you've done this
that when something is said explicitly
from the heart
it doesn't actually come out of the
character's mouth
as you watch you know there's the the
dinner scene where it's a kind of
ventriloquism
you know tusker declares his love
for sam but doesn't read it himself so
sam has to read it
this letter to his this love letter to
himself
um then listens to the narration of his
own voice
and something equivalent happens here
you know
husker makes the most honest statement
he's ever gonna make
but he has to sit as a listener rather
than you know we don't see his lips move
in that moment
and but sam having forced this
out into the open and it gets physical
you know in order to face this i'm going
to have to physically restrain you
yeah we're going to listen to this sound
of you saying this stuff
but then what does sam do after that he
says let's we're gonna pretend it never
happened
so having let the thing out he then
wants to put the lid back on
and say okay that's acknowledged now now
we can go back to normal
and none of this ever happened very
english
yes
but it's also a reaction to sheer terror
and
to inevitability you know the sheer
brutal
inevitability of what they're facing
yeah yeah i think there's something
um that i noticed again watching it
uh earlier today which i'd which i
talked to
to dick about at the time and i i
suppose must have spoken to you guys
as well about uh briefly in terms of
specifically you calling
but the the the dictaphone the the voice
recorder it feels to me like
always felt like a smoking gun and it's
sort of the placement of it
in the scene in the context of youtube i
mean it's literally in between you guys
just sort of hovering
at the bottom of the frame um kind of
like you know benign and um
but it's but it's the most potent thing
there you know
i think that that's quite interesting in
the way that it was blocked
to reveal that um that particular device
always felt to me quite um
a powerful a powerful thing um
yeah it just occurred to me when i
watched it before
yeah yeah
it's interesting because it's different
uses sorry
no no i was just going to say yes that
that
is wonderful it's just sort of sitting
there
you know it's this little time bomb and
but also you asked about
like how did it set up the rest of the
the shoot which was only another couple
days really
wasn't it it set it up
brilliantly because then we had those
variant
intent even more intense scenes to do
after after that and the way you shot
this
helped catapult me emotionally
into into doing
into doing those scenes well yes
and i think for what sam because they're
both handling it differently obviously
um and that's what leads to
confrontation because they
they they don't have they have a
completely
conflicting um
their conflicting agenda um yeah
so the next time you see sam he's trying
to enforce the thing he just said we're
gonna do we're gonna
you know take the dog for a walk and
then we're gonna sit down we're gonna
have dinner
and none of this happened and of course
had you know this enormous um
cats out of the bag now uh and
you know so sam's now trying to follow
through with that and
in this rather uh uneasy
hectic uh way
um goes on a tear of being normal
oh we could go to france i mean you know
this is why we bought the trailer we
could do that and
joke joke joke and uh what's that place
we used to go in and you liked it
it is pathetically unconvincing
you know and tusk is sitting opposite
him saying look why are we doing
it what are you doing you know this
this is out now you know we have to we
have to face it uh
for real and and sam is still in the
early stages of those
those of those last scenes trying to
just trying to put the cat back in the
back yeah and the
you know yeah and the and the guy who is
losing top touch with reality
um you know tusker
is the guy who knows that there can be
nothing but reality
now yeah because
it's all going to disappear so you have
to
be as truthful as possible now
otherwise otherwise that might not even
be possible
[Music]
six months down the line yeah just a
mess
yeah well thanks guys it was uh
lovely to talk to you about it thank you
harry
let's revisit it see you soon next week
we'll be discussing c93
there was no scene 93 but we're going to
discuss it anyway
that's it anyway thank you thank you
thank you
bye colin